tatiana jaroslav celebran en su casa de
zamorilla la pascua ortodoxa en plena
guerra esta familia vive a tan sólo 50
km de las tropas rusas desde que empezó
la guerra se resguardan cuando oyen el
sonido de las sirenas temen acudir a la
iglesia después de los últimos ataques
de rusia cuando escuchamos que rusia
habla de provocaciones entendemos que
ellos lo harán las noticias de ayer de
lo que hicieron en odessa muchas
personas murieron para que ellos solo
bombardean con cohetes edificios como
éste venden line wind y hoy es día de
celebración de juntarse con toda la
familia peroza por ella más de la mitad
de la población ha dejado sus hogares y
esta ceremonia se vive con inquietud son
borradas na no trigo gago tutu sigue
llorando me gustaría sentir alegría pero
no puedo evitar sentir inquietud no me
puedo lavar la cabeza porque cuando voy
al baño suena una alarma y tendré que
correr con la cabeza mojada que se me
ofrece wifi 6
a pt y cuando preparó la comida me
levanto a las cinco y las seis de la
mañana empezarán las alarmas me abucheen
anexionado 6 sin embargo en la iglesia
ortodoxa ucraniana des beato poco ves
que la guerra no ha paralizado la
celebración de la resurrección de jesús
a pesar de las amenazas muchos
ciudadanos han decidido venir aquí a la
principal iglesia ortodoxa de zamorilla
para celebrar la pascua ortodoxa
es villana es profesora en un colegio de
zamorilla y reza cada noche para que su
ciudad no termine como la martirizada
mariupol
[Música]
y esto después de chiquitas tengo fe en
que dios nos protegerá que ningún misil
caerá en nuestra tierra de sap orinar
aquí están
y la virgen de poco ha cubierto con un
manto asa polilla y estaremos a salvo
donde aparece sin esperanza de una paz
cercana los que se quedan rezan porque
la invasión rusa termine pronto